My grandfather was a restaurant owner.
My father was a restaurant owner.
My name is Vincent Yeow Lim.
I'm a chef, content creator
and restaurant owner.
Owning and running a Chinese restaurant
is one of the hardest and most valuable
things I think you can do.
When we first arrived in Australia,
my dad opened a Chinese restaurant.
I would go there
every single day to help him out.
That was my way to spend time with him.
And slowly I developed
my love for cooking.
At the age of 15,
I was able to use a wok
to cook and to serve customers.
Now I’m running
a 100-seater Chinese restaurant.
The hard work that I saw my dad
put into Chinese food
makes me feel really proud.
Proud that I was lucky enough
to learn from a master.
When I tell people
that I'm a chef cooking Chinese food,
I want people to value it
the same way that I do.
So what is the value of Chinese food?
Is it the taste?
Is it the hard work and the training?
Or is it the dish's history
and the nostalgia it makes us feel?
To me, it is all of those things.
But being in the restaurant industry,
I can tell you the most
obvious value of food.
And that is the price
at which we choose to set it at.
The perception of Chinese food
is that it is indulgent,
yet cheap.
But the value of Chinese food
is so much more than that.
There is no formal culinary school
to train to be a Chinese chef.
And after the pandemic,
there was a shortage
of Chinese chefs in Australia.
Now the cost of ingredients,
labor
and demand for Chinese food is high.
The amount of skill required
to cook the first dish that I ever learned
doesn't match up to the price.
The first dish that I ever learned
to cook was the fried rice.
Fried rice is the easiest dish to cook,
but also the hardest dish to get right.
I actually wasn't allowed
to serve customers
until I got this dish right.
(Laughter)
The oil goes into the wok first,
but only when the wok is hot enough.
The egg goes in next.
This creates a nonstick coating
for when the rice hits the hot wok.
(Stove beeps)
From experience, you can tell
when the rice is too wet
or if the wok is too hot or too cold.
All these small factors
will create a different end result.
If the rice is too wet,
you lose the smoky aromatic flavor.
But if the rice is too dry,
you're basically eating pebbles.
(Laughter)
Now we add a little bit of yum, yum.
Now we add the cooked
meats and vegetables.
I'm tossing it to combine the flavors
of the meat and vegetables with the rice.
Even if we were to remove
all the meat and vegetables,
your rice should still
have all the flavor.
(Sizzling)
From years of experience,
I can tell you the difference
between a good fried rice
just from the feel and from the smell,
without even having to take a bite.
(Applause)
And I thought --
I thought that was enough.
But I realized cooking with one wok
was way too slow.
So I took the knowledge from my dad
and taught myself
the dual wok cooking technique,
using two woks to cook
two different dishes at the same time.
This requires coordination,
organization and years of training.
What makes it harder is the combination
of dishes coming up next.
They have endless possibilities.
Chow mein, sizzling garlic prawns,
egg foo young.
When one is cooking, the other is served.
When the other is cooking,
the next is served.
The goal is that
no matter the combination,
all the dishes get to the table
at the same time.
People expect this
in a Chinese restaurant.
People expect variety.
In a Western restaurant,
you open the menu,
there's 20 items.
When I first started, I had 300.
(Laughter)
In a Western restaurant,
you can often judge the food by the decor,
the plating of the dishes
or even by the number
of different forks for each course.
But in a Chinese restaurant,
it's a little bit different.
You can often judge it
by things like the kids sitting
on the first table doing their homework.
That's when you know a Chinese restaurant
will have amazing food.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
I was that kid.
(Laughter)
To a lot of us Chinese immigrants
who started our own restaurants,
the restaurant isn't just a business.
It's a part of our lives.
We eat almost three meals a day there,
and often we just use our homes
as a place to sleep.
We dedicate our lives to these restaurants
and to making delicious food.
In Chinese cooking,
we use a lot of strong flavors
like ginger, garlic, chilies
and even shrimp paste.
The different flavors, I think,
are why people like Chinese food,
because every bite is different,
and you never really get bored.
But flavors, flavors are also built
with the tools we use.
When you use a wok, you get wok hei,
known as "breath of the dragon."
Wok hei is the reason why noodles and rice
always taste better at a restaurant
than when you try to cook it at home.
Wok hei is the combustion
of oils in the air
that make that smoky aromatic flavor.
But wok hei also tastes like nostalgia.
Growing up in Malaysia,
the kitchens are outside, just like this.
You can smell every ingredient
that goes into the wok.
The air is thick with humidity,
and the fragrances of the food,
they linger around so much longer.
Those memories, they become nostalgic.
The sense of home is what I feel
when I taste Chinese wok cooking.
Nostalgia is what makes a good dish
taste ten times better
and that much more valuable.
But the value of Chinese food
is often compared to fast food,
quick and cheap.
Although we've spent years
developing skills to cook faster,
Chinese food isn't fast food.
It requires skills,
mastery of ingredients and nostalgia.
In 2017, my dad passed away.
I looked up to him.
He was my best friend.
When he passed away, I realized --
I realized my passion of cooking dishes
from my childhood.
I was working as a chef at an airline’s
first class lounge at the time,
but I didn't have any memories
of the dishes I was cooking.
I wanted to feel closer to my dad.
So I quit.
I dropped out of university
on my last semester.
I hopped onto a plane,
and I flew over here to Sydney.
And I took over the restaurant
that I own today.
I wanted to record everything
that my dad taught me,
so I shared it on social media.
It went viral.
Hundreds of millions of views.
A lot of people related
to the recipes that I was cooking
because it was what they grew up eating
with their parents.
I remember this one fried rice he made.
I was eight years old at the time.
It was the first time I recall my dad
stepping into the kitchen cooking.
He made this fried rice
with spam, seafood, peas
and a little bit of dark soy sauce.
It was a little bit salty,
but it was the best fried rice
that I've ever had.
I cook and I've always cooked
because it was a way to connect to my dad.
It was something that we shared.
Cooking represents all the hard work
and memories that we had,
learning the art, mastering the skills
and understanding
the history of Chinese food.
To me, the value of Chinese food
is so much more than the prices
you pay at my restaurant.
So the next time
you visit a Chinese restaurant,
just remember.
It's not just a plate of fried rice.
It's so much more than that.
Thank you.
(Applause)